[Música]
sutiss que atraviesan el país a 200
kilómetros por hora en sus periodos
cargados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cool bars que cargan lavavajillas y
televisores sobre sus espaldas a través
de las montañas kurdas
y chuck bass que arriesgan su vida para
transportar diesel a través del desierto
estos hombres son los contrabandistas
del irán actual
[Música]
a pesar de sus abundantes reservas de
petróleo universidades y monumentos de
la antigua persia miran es un país en el
que un tercio de la población vive en la
pobreza
tras décadas de sanciones
internacionales y corrupción la
república islámica tiene una tasa de
desempleo juvenil de 24%
alcohol
tenis de marca
iphones y muchos productos prohibidos
más del 36 por ciento de la economía
iraní está en el sector informal
y lo informal es sinónimo de contrabando
ubicado en la ruta de la seda irán es un
cruce histórico del comercio entre
oriente y occidente
en el occidente del país los cubars
kurdos transportan bienes de consumo a
través de las montañas desde el vecino
kurdistán iraquí en el oriente los sub
bars transportan gasolina y diésel a
través de las mesetas del desierto hacia
pakistán y los sutiss llevan mercancías
de ciudad en ciudad a toda velocidad por
todo el país
una carrera nocturna
2 sutiss atraviesan el país
el velocímetro marca 200 kilómetros por
hora
adelanta y pierde el control del
vehículo
[Música]
este video fue publicado en la cuenta de
instagram boras jan shot y por ascán es
una región en el sureste de irán en
instagram cientos de cuentas como esta
cuenta en la vida de los hutis en
diferentes partes del país estas cuentas
glorifican el estilo de vida de los
hutis con tomas de cerca de los
velocímetros que a veces superan los 180
o 200 kilómetros por hora
estas cuentas son anónimas los huthis
ocultan su identidad y con razón ya que
si son atrapados pueden ir directamente
a la cárcel
sin embargo tres de ellos accedieron a
hablar con nosotros a través de
instagram su red social favorito uno de
ellos maneja esta cuenta lo llamaremos
servín hablamos con él por primera vez
hace tres años es graduado en ingeniería
mecánica
busque trabajo como ingeniero pero no
había trabajo además estoy casado pero
fue muy costoso y ahora estamos
endeudados gano mucho dinero como chut y
si no hiciera este trabajo no tendría
nada más que hacer ganó entre 7 y 12
millones de toman es por un viaje de mil
kilómetros desde mi ciudad hasta teherán
nuestros ingresos dependen de lo que
transportamos y entre qué ciudades los
sutiss transportan todo tipo de
mercancías del kurdistán iraquí traen
alcohol que está prohibido en irán
transportan cigarrillos y celulares a
través del golfo pérsico entre los
productos más codiciados están los
suplementos dietéticos para el
fisioculturismo las piezas de
automóviles y motos y la ropa de alta
costura los huthis conducen
principalmente autos peugeot y citroën
que son fabricados en irán bajo licencia
desde hace décadas los contrabandistas
los modifican para transportar cargas
pesadas a gran velocidad
tenemos que cambiar la suspensión de
nuestros autos reforzamos los brazos de
la suspensión para hacerlos más rígidos
y subimos la suspensión para que los
vehículos puedan soportar cargas más
pesadas
también calibramos el motor para que sea
capaz de transportar cargas pesadas a
altas velocidades
[Música]
[Aplausos]
normalmente llegar a teherán toma 6
horas pero nosotros lo hacemos en dos
horas y media eso significa una
velocidad de más de 200 kilómetros por
hora
para evitar ser arrestados los sutiss
recurren a dispositivos al estilo de
james bond
utilizamos matrículas falsas para que la
policía no pueda rastrear los
las máquinas de humo también son muy
populares
también lo son estos clavos que pueden
pinchar los neumáticos de quienes los
persiguen estos dispositivos funcionan
bien durante los controles policiales
ordinarios cuando la policía empieza a
perseguirnos
[Música]
pero si la policía organiza una
operación a gran escala los dispositivos
no servirán de nada la policía utiliza
varios autos helicópteros es imposible
librarse de esa situación
no viajamos solos es más seguro viajar
en convoy eso también nos permite llevar
más cosas normalmente hay entre 9 y 10
autos
un vehículo siempre permanece adelante
de 5 a 10 minutos antes del convoy su
conductor no lleva ninguna carga
su función es advertir se hay controles
policiales
también tenemos autos de bloqueo que se
utilizan justamente para bloquear el
camino de la policía cuando nos
persiguen
[Música]
en irán los contrabandistas se enfrentan
a multas de entre 2 y 10 veces el valor
de su mercancía los conductores pueden
ser condenados hasta 5 años de prisión
el riesgo en este trabajo depende de lo
que uno transporte si el valor de la
carga supera los 10 millones de toman es
la policía la confiscará junto con el
vehículo si la policía nos persigue y
creemos que no podemos escapar nos
paramos y le prendemos fuego al auto
antes de que puedan arrestar nos para
que no se pueda estimar el valor de la
carga
pero hay un riesgo aún mayor que el de
ser descubierto no existen estadísticas
precisas sobre el número de sutiss que
mueren cada año pero según servín en su
región ocurren accidentes casi todas las
semanas tenemos que conducir rápido es
la única manera de escapar de la policía
cuando nos persigue así que pisó el
acelerador y voy tan rápido como el auto
lo permite morir en un accidente es un
temor constante para mí
literalmente pienso en eso todas las
noches tengo miedo de morir en un
incendio a veces cuando conduzco tengo
tanto miedo que me prometo a mí mismo
que ese será mi último viaje
se desconoce el número total de yuty se
miran en un excepcional comunicado
oficial la policía de la provincia
oriental iraní de lorestán afirmó haber
inmovilizado más de 3 mil 800 vehículos
sutiss en un año entre 2019 y 2020
en las regiones áridas del sureste de
irán los contrabandistas sub bars
atraviesan el desierto a toda velocidad
en sus vehículos y van dice lee gasolina
a pakistán
estos enormes convoys dejan rastros
visibles desde el espacio sub bars
significa transportadores de combustible
después de décadas de sequía en la
región muchos contrabandistas dicen no
poder encontrar otro trabajo hoffman es
uno de los miles de iraníes que trafican
con combustible a lo largo de esta
peligrosa frontera tienen que esquivar
tanto a los guardias fronterizos iraníes
como a los paquistaníes
antes no era tan difícil pero los
iraníes aumentaron los controles
instalaron más puestos de control
patrullas y barreras a lo largo de las
zonas no montañosas de la frontera para
que no podamos cruzar ponemos
contenedores de plástico en nuestras
camionetas y los llenamos de combustible
sobre todo de diésel porque es menos
inflamable que la gasolina así que es
menos peligroso tomamos la carretera y
luego nos vamos hacia las montañas
[Música]
abrirse paso por las montañas puede ser
complicado y aguas bajas
así que
una vez llegamos a la región fronteriza
hay que bombear el combustible de los
tanques paquistaníes
jolie
como todo
el diesel que los contrabandistas
compran en grandes cantidades en irán se
vende hasta 70 veces más caro una vez en
pakistán
si eres un simple conductor como yo que
no tiene vehículo recibes una suma de un
millón 500 de toman es la mayor parte
del dinero va para los jefes que tienen
entre 10 y 15 conductores trabajando
para ellos este trabajo es muy peligroso
a veces tenemos que conducir muy rápido
para escapar de la policía a veces las
autoridades nos disparan y por eso los
vehículos pueden incendiarse
en febrero de 2021 las fuerzas de
seguridad iraníes abrieron fuego contra
un convoy de su barça cerca de la ciudad
de san gerardo
según los activistas locales 10 de los
contrabandistas murieron los habitantes
indignados bloquearon las carreteras
atacaron la oficina del gobernador e
incendiaron patrullas de policía
líderes locales les pidieron a las
fuerzas de seguridad que procedieran con
moderación según ellos los sub bar no
son delincuentes y no tienen más
alternativa que este trabajo para
alimentar a sus familias pidieron que se
procesará a todos los responsables de
este accidente he perdido a muchos
amigos y colegas que se dedicaban a este
trabajo cuando la policía nos dispara no
les importa que vayan a matar al único
proveedor de toda una familia el
ministerio de petróleo iraní calcula que
cada día se transportan más de 8
millones de litros de combustible a
pakistán y afganistán
esta cifra equivale a 3 mil camionetas
se les llama cool bars a aquellos que
llevan la mercancía sobre sus espaldas
cientos de ellos cruzan a pie las
montañas del oeste de irán y a veces
cargan hasta 70 kilos encima los cool
bar son parte de la minoría kurda de
irak realizan viajes regulares a través
de las montañas del kurdistán iraquí
porque mira que los productos son más
económicos y de más fácil acceso que en
irán pero la zona fronteriza es
peligrosa y está muy vigilada
corremos el riesgo de caer en las
montañas en invierno hay heladas
incluso en minas y sobre todo los
guardias fronterizos iraníes nos
disparan
[Música]
hay tantos desempleados que muchos
trabajan como cool bars adolescentes
ancianos
se salta
volvería que en la sesión sol
traemos muchas cosas del kurdistán
iraquí ropa zapatos alcohol
electrodomésticos nos pagan por kilo
puedo llevar entre 55 y 63 kilogramos en
la espalda algunas personas pueden
cargar hasta 70 kilogramos ganamos unos
500 mil toman es por viaje el año pasado
gané 32 millones de tomares lo cual no
es mucho cuando tienes una familia de 4
personas
trabajamos según el clima y la presencia
de los guardias fronterizos trabajamos
sobre todo en primavera y verano un poco
menos en otoño y mucho menos en invierno
tal vez diez veces durante esta estación
[Música]
es un trabajo muy peligroso si es que se
le puede llamar trabajo el verano pasado
me caí por un precipicio y tuve que
quedarme en casa durante un mes perdí
muchos ingresos por eso el año pasado
uno de mis amigos falleció por una caída
en las montañas y otro perdió las dos
piernas por la explosión de una mina
pero el mayor peligro sigue siendo la
guardia fronteriza iraní los líderes
políticos incluido el propio líder
supremo alí jamenéi han pedido que se
deje de atacar a los cool bares pues
estos afirman que cuando los guardias
fronterizos iraníes disparan es para
matar según las ong kurdas más de 200
cool bars murieron a causa de las balas
de los guardias fronterizos entre marzo
de 2020 y marzo de 2021
los guardias fronterizos saben que sólo
somos culparse los milicianos pero
disparan de todos modos
los guardias fronterizos me dispararon
varias veces afortunadamente no me
alcanzaron por el momento pero perdí
cuatro amigos en esos tiroteos
todos los contrabandistas con los que
hablamos tenían amigos que habían muerto
realizando esta actividad todos dicen
que preferirían estar haciendo un
trabajo legal pero que no tienen otra
opción y con el aumento de los precios
de los alimentos en 2022 la corrupción
rampante y las continuas sanciones
internacionales son muy pesimistas en
cuanto a la posibilidad de cambiar de
vida algún día